what is up everybody its Animak here for anime
uproar and in this video I will be ranking the top
10 strongest characters in the entire seven deadly
sins series after making videos ranking every
member of the demon clan and every member of the
goddess clan we received very positive feedback
and a lot of you wanted to see who I think are the
top 10 strongest characters overall all races and
clans included in this video I will be doing just
that and I will give you my logic for why I am
ranking them in this particular order to make my
decision I will use power level abilities battle
capability and accomplished feats to determine
their ranking that said this is not an exact
science so if you disagree please don't hesitate
to comment and give me your reasoning down below
I'd love to hear from you before we jump into the
list I want to give a big thank you to Grand Chase
for sponsoring this video the official sequel to
the popular Grand Chase RPG has just been launched
and it is jam-packed with explosive real-time
action and strategy you can choose from dozens
of characters including all 19 that were featured
in the original Grand Chase and some brand new
characters as well and you can jump right into
the action taking on swathes of enemies at the
same time and using epic battle combos to take
them out in style you can even set up a team of
up to four characters and hack and slash a barrage
of monsters at once one thing I love about this
game is that instead of fighting every enemy one
by one until your hand cramps up you can gather a
bunch of monsters into a group and slay them all
in epic fashion not to mention that you get to
play with beautiful magical waifu's and if there
is one thing that a 7 Deadly Sins fan like me can
appreciate its beautiful magical waifu's this game
is extremely rewarding even for players who don't
want to spend a bunch of extra money so be sure
to click that link in the description and check
it out for yourself it's free heads up I will
be assessing each character's strength at their
peak so that means that even if the character
is currently a lot weaker than they were before
or even if they are currently dead I will still
talk about them when they were at their absolute
strongest point in the store if you enjoy this
type of video and you want to see more be sure
to leave a like to let me know and if you're new
to the channel don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell please keep in mind that
this video will use information all the way up
to the latest chapters of the manga so there
will be manga spoilers if you're an anime only
fan there are some big twists coming up that you
still haven't seen in the enemy so this is your
warning and now let's get it started at number
10 the goddess Elizabeth in her original body
Elizabeth was a member of the goddess clan and the
daughter of the supreme deity of the ruler of the
entire goddess clan before she was killed and
then cursed by her mother to keep reincarnating
as a human over and over again which was her
punishment for falling in love with a demon ie
male Yodas Elizabeth was one of the highest-ranked
goddesses and she demonstrated incredible power
during the previous holy war 3,000 years ago her
exact strength is difficult to pinpoint because
we don't have a power level for her from back when
she was a goddess and she is also opposed to death
and violence so she does her best to always avoid
it but we do know that when she was a goddess she
took on both mon speed and derriere e in there
in do de forms and was able to purify them with
her power knocking them unconscious and reverting
them back to their normal demon forms in the past
Elizabeth has also demonstrated powerful abilities
directly related to empathy and these abilities
enable her to speak directly to the hearts of her
opponents and make them lose the will to fight
and we've actually seen her convince an entire
army of demons to stop fighting the Archangel
male at one point compared Elizabeth's strength
to the strength of meliodas and the Archangel
lunar shell so that places Elizabeth and the
company of some of the strongest characters in
the entire series and this is why she lands at
number 10 on our list at number 9 the Archangel
Ludo shell the leader of the four Archangels Ludo
shell is currently possessing the body of Princess
Margaret the sister of Elizabeth Leonys as one
of the four Archangels Lou Rochelle has a gray
called flash which enables him to move with super
speed making him one of the fastest characters
in the series while inside Margaret's human body
Ludo shells power level has been measured at 200
and 1000 but we can assume that in his original
goddess body which does not have the limitation
of human bodies Ludo shell would have been even
stronger although it is difficult to say exactly
how much stronger he would have been while
some characters on this list like Elizabeth
want to avoid violence in conflict Ludo shell is
ruthless and aggressive and he believes that the
holy war is a good thing because it gives him the
opportunity to destroy the demon clan based on his
strength and ruthlessness but also keeping in mind
that we have seen him get overpowered before by
other characters including Delhi Aryan Mon speed
in Endora and also zelgius with ominous nebula
Ludo Shah lands at number 9 on our list at number
8 King with fully-grown wings Harlequin the king
of the fairies also known as the grizzly sin of
sloth King is one of the weakest characters in the
seven deadly sins when it comes to pure physical
strength however as the current fairy king he
possesses enormous magical power and during the
big mile slash esta rosa fight in the manga King
awakens his full potential and attains a new
form as his fairy wings finally grow to their
full size coming to resemble the large wings that
the first fairy King gloxinia had instead of the
little baby wings that king used to have and with
this transformation King attains a completely new
level of power now King is a character for whom
the last accurately recorded power level is pretty
much meaningless since his last power level was
only about 41,000 but in this new form King is
on a completely different level he is able to hear
the hearts of those around him essentially reading
their mind including their innermost thoughts
and using his true chasta full and its many forms
he is able to defeat Maya Lin his corrupted form
relatively easily now when we think about how much
trouble everyone else was having fighting mile
after he had absorbed multiple Commandments and
when we think about the fact that in this form a
mile seemingly destroyed is they re and both sorry
L ant army oh it's easy to start thinking that
maybe King has now reached the status of one of
the strongest characters in the entire series and
while he now definitely belongs in the top ten it
is also important to remember that at the point
at which King faced him Myles body was already
being torn apart from the inside by multiple
commandments so it is possible that this was part
of the reason why King was able to defeat Myles so
easily nevertheless King wit his full power awaken
and his wings fully grown is much stronger than
he was before and he is now definitely a force
to be reckoned with especially since all the
ladies know that when it comes to fairy wings
size matters at number seven Merlin the Boers sin
of gluttony Merlin is the most powerful mage in
all of Britannia and we know that she has been
alive for more than 3,000 years in fact thirty
centuries before the story begins Merlin knew
and was close to the original Elizabeth in her
goddess body Merlin was born in beli Alwyn a city
once known as the capital of the Wizards and she
immediately became famous due to the fact that she
was born with infinite magic this infinite magic
is so rare and so powerful that the goddess and
demon clans both tried to get Merlin to come over
to their side during the previous holy war and
they each offered her secret magical knowledge
and abilities in return for her support but rather
than picking either side Merlin just took the
knowledge offered by both sides and because they
were tricked by Merlin the rulers of the goddess
and demon clans were so mad that they destroyed
the entire city of Vallejo Luwin although Merlin
survived of course as should be obvious by now
Merlin has immense magical powers and possesses
many unique magical abilities one of her special
abilities is infinity which enables her to make
her spells lost forever and she even used one of
her spells to stop her own body from aging at age
30 making her virtually immortal and also making
her ESCA Norse eternal waifu her magic abilities
are considered to be in a totally different league
from ordinary wizards and mages and she even has
an ability known as absolute cancel which allows
her to cancel out and erase the spells of others
Merlin has so many different magical abilities and
items that there is no way to list them all here
but it's enough to say that she can use everything
from teleportation to spells like perfect cube and
exterminate ray and of course she possess a secret
magical knowledge from both the demon and goddess
clans because she succeeded in tricking the demon
king and the supreme deity so many years ago on
top of all that Merlin has a mysterious ace up her
sleeve called the morning star of all Dan that we
still don't know very much about the morning star
wall Dan is the name of Merlin's sacred treasure
and it is clear that it has insane magical power
but it's important to point out that it's true
nature and potential are still largely a mystery
which makes me think that this particular sacred
treasure will play an important role in the story
at some point in the future in Chapter 292 we got
a great glimpse of Merlin's potential as she uses
complex layers of magic to cast multiple spells
which absolutely ruined Chandler and ku sucks day
and we can only imagine what else Merlin has in
store for us in the future for that reason and of
course because of her insane magical abilities in
general Merlin ranks at number 7 on our list
at number 6 the original goal thir the demon
goal thir the person who created the dog othor
died long before the current story of the seven
deadly sins ever got going but the more the story
goes on the more we come to understand that Gotha
played a huge role in shaping the current world
of the seven deadly sins it is hard to say how
strong he would be in a one-on-one battle because
he died so long ago and his powers are less about
direct physical conflict and more about long-range
magic and mental manipulation but it is clear that
during his lifetime goal there was an incredibly
powerful wizard so much so that the demon king
forced him to become one of the ten commandments
against his will because the demon king thought
that Gotha was too valuable to the demon clan to
be allowed to simply do as he pleased the original
goal was also the teacher and master of Merlin
so we can assume that Golder taught Merlin many
of the incredible abilities that she possesses
today and his magic is so sophisticated that he
was able to create an artificial doll and still
make that doll one of the most powerful warriors
in the world a warrior capable of becoming a
member of the ten commandments and of the seven
deadly sins and just like the doll go through
the original goal Thur had this special ability
known as invasion which allowed him to read and
manipulate the thoughts and memories of other
creatures as we eventually learn in the manga go
Thurs magic was so strong that he was able to end
the previous holy war by manipulating the memories
of a vast number of individuals on both sides of
the conflict including the demon king himself even
though we never quite see him fighting an opponent
one-on-one in the traditional way the fact that
the original goal Terk and manipulate the minds of
so many creatures from a long distance including
the mind of the demon king himself means that
Golder is overall one of the strongest characters
in the seven deadly sins after all why even bother
getting into a one-on-one battle if you can mess
with your opponent's mind before he ever gets a
chance to meet you face to face and now moving
into the top five at number five Zell drous
zelgius is the youngest son of the demon king and
he is acting as the demon Kings representative
zelgius has ambitions of becoming the next
demon king and because he possesses power that
he borrowed directly from the demon king himself
sometimes referred to as the power of God even the
highest ranked demons like Chandler and Cusack are
both impressed and intimidated by the potential
power that zelgius possesses although I feel that
Zell drous definitely deserves a spot on this
list he is one of the most difficult characters
to actually rank accurately for one thing the
highest recorded power level that we have for him
was recorded long before the recent events in the
manga that power level was 61 thousand but a lot
has changed since then and zelgius could easily
be three times stronger than that now if not more
the other reason why I think cel just is so hard
to rank is that I don't think he has shown us his
full potential yet as the direct representative of
the demon king he has unique powers the no other
higher ring demon has and there is no accurate
way to predict the true extent of his power in the
video where I ranked all the demons from weakest
the strongest I actually placed zelgius behind the
original goal third but with the latest chapters
in the manga giving us a better idea of the extent
of Zelda's true power I decided to place him ahead
of goal thir this time around some of Zelda says
known abilities include Desiree which lets him
create a portal to a specific target and strike
the target down with a lightning bolt and ominous
nebula which allows him to generate a dark vortex
that sucks in all living things and then instantly
cuts them to pieces when thinking about how strong
zell just really is we can't forget that he almost
killed Merlin during the core and arc and she
was barely saved by Elizabeth's healing powers
and when zelgius used ominous nebulae on Eskin
or Merlin and the Archangel lunar shell at the
same time he was giving them a lot of trouble
and he was only stopped by Eskin or when he
reached his most overpowered form known as the
one the Archangel looter shell whose grace flash
is known for giving him incredible SuperSpeed
admits that ominous nebula is actually faster
than his grace and for all these reasons zelgius
makes it into the top 5 on our list at number 4
askin or askin or is a 40 year old human and if
that was all he was then he certainly wouldn't be
anywhere close to the top 10 strongest characters
in the seven deadly sins but he was born with a
very unique power at night ESCA noir is by far
the weakest of the seven deadly sins and one of
the weakest characters in the entire series but
as the Sun begins to rise each day s cars power
grows immensely every hour until it reaches
its maximum height at noon as his power grows
so does his body he becomes incredibly tall and
muscular until he reaches his peak at noon each
day at noon s Connors power is at its highest
point for one minute and at this time s Kannur
is able to enter a state known as the one in the
past Merlin stated them when this happens s Kannur
is easily the strongest of the seven deadly sins
as he becomes an invincible incarnation of power
the name of s Kannur sacred treasure is the
divine axe Rita a heavy battle axe which he
uses in conjunction with his special ability
to deal devastating them two opponents later
in the manga we realized that as canora's unique
ability is actually called sunshine the divine
grace that once belonged to the strongest of the
four Archangels my L but somehow this incredible
power passed on to s Kannur because of the wild
fluctuations of his power between day and night it
is virtually impossible to measure the true extent
of s Connors power especially when he is in the
state known as the one his power level has been
measured at well over 100,000 but judging from
his feats and his ability to effectively challenge
meliodas esta rosa and zelgius while he is using
ominous nebulae it is clear that at the peak of
his power s kannur is way stronger than 100,000
however before you scream out praise the Sun s
kannur is number one and proceed to smash your
laptop in anger that I ranked him at number four
we have to remember that as a human s kannur does
have some clear weaknesses that keep him from
being ranked even higher on this list for one
thing the peak of his power lasts for only one
minute a day and for the rest of the day he is
much weaker especially at night what's more a high
ranked demon like Chandler can actually force s
Kannur to turn back into his weak nighttime form
even in the middle of the day by using darkness
which is the demonic ability to block out the Sun
by surrounding everything with darkness as a human
he is also not immortal so he could technically
be killed especially if he is caught by a powerful
enemy while he is vulnerable such as at night
lastly using the form called the one is known
to strain s Connors body making him potentially
weak and vulnerable as soon as the effects of the
one wear off it is absolutely true that under
the ideal circumstances s Kannur is one of the
strongest characters on this list but because of
the clear weaknesses that I mentioned he lands
at number four on our list at number three Melly
Otis the oldest son of the demon king Melly Otis
was cursed by his father so that he cannot die
or he can technically but he just comes back to
life and this makes meliodas essentially immortal
although every time he is killed and comes back
to life he comes back with less of his genuine
emotions so he becomes more cruel and ruthless
after unlocking his demonic powers and while
in his assault mode Melly Otis's power level
was at 140 mm but that is before malleolus begins
absorbing five of the demon Kings Commandments in
an attempt to challenge the demon king and remove
the curse that was placed on him at this point in
the manga the power of meliodas is definitely
well over 140 mm and we could assume that if he
successfully absorbs the five commandments which
would amount to a quarter of the demon Kings power
meliodas could easily be pushing a power level of
300,000 we will have to wait and see how powerful
the new malleolus is going to be but even before
this future powerup malleolus was shown to be able
to take on zelgius esta rosa and Cusack at the
same time on top of that in purgatory meliodas
emotions meaning only one part of meliodas are
able to face off against the demon king with the
help of bond and wild but well this is definitely
an impressive feat it is important to know that
at this point meliodas is still no match for
the demon king he managed to land a blow on the
demon king only after sixty years of fighting him
unsuccessfully with the help of wild and bon and
he managed to do it only after finally learning
to unleash his original power but of course after
he absorbs the commandments and or after he is
reunited with his emotions and becomes whole again
Mele Otis's power will rise exponentially and at
that point we may have to reevaluate this list but
right now I have to place him at number three
at number two the Archangel mile back when he
still had his grace sunshine lunar shells younger
brother mile is confirmed to be the strongest out
of the four Archangels and a single most powerful
warrior of the goddess clan among the goddesses
his strength is second only to the supreme deity
even without his grace called sunshine which is
currently possessed by eScan or miles power level
is believed to be over two hundred thousand and
although absorbing multiple Commandments
definitely contributed to this if we just
look at how strong s Kannur is thanks to sunshine
despite being just a human it is easy to conclude
that mile in his far more powerful goddess body
using sunshine or maybe even using the one would
be an unstoppable force during the previous holy
war miles strength was compared to the strength of
Mellie Otis and after meliodas switched sides
and decided to join the goddess clan the only
way to give the demons a fighting chance and stop
the holy war from turning into a war of complete
annihilation was for the original goal third to
manipulate the memories of everyone who knew my el
including my himself and make him take melioidosis
place as the love of the ten commandments once
this occurred the goddess clan no longer had a
chance to defeat the demon clan outright so they
decided to sacrifice their own physical bodies in
order to seal the demons away inside the coffin of
eternal darkness now I know that a lot of people
down in the comments are going to say that peak
meliodas is stronger than peak mile because Mellie
Otis is the main characters so of course he will
eventually become stronger and yes that is very
likely going to happen once meliora succeeds in
absorbing the five commandments or maybe even all
ten commandments however as of the making of this
video I think that we have to conclude that my
El with sunshine at his peak would be stronger
than mellitus before he absorbs the commandments
and since we still haven't seen what Mellie Otis
is capable of after absorbing the commandments I
chose to put mile ahead of him for now but if you
disagree it's totally cool feel free to give
me your reasoning down in the comments below
and finally at number one Lord Twigg oh I'm only
kidding guys everyone knows that Lord Twigg owes
power cannot be contained by any single series or
franchise so at number one we have the demon king
and the supreme deity the number one strongest pot
is shared by two beings at the same time the ruler
of the demon clan and the ruler of the goddess
clan and although you might think this is some
kind of cop-out and that I should have found a
way to determine which of the two is stronger if
we go by the information that we have so far all
we've been told is that the demon king and supreme
deity are extremely powerful that they are the
most powerful members of their respective clans
and that they are both evenly matched the demon
king is the father of meliora sons eldress and
he created the ten commandments by dividing his
own power in half and then granting 1/10 of that
power to each of the commandments so if we put
all ten of the commandments together all should
measure up to only half of the demon Kings full
potential the demon king also has some extremely
opie abilities including the ruler a magical power
that lets him reverse all attacks used against him
so that instead of hurting him they actually make
him stronger he can also manipulate the elements
grant powers to others as was the case with the
commandments and plays nearly unbreakable curses
on people as was the case with meliodas the demon
Kings exact power level has not been mentioned
yet although based on the power of the individual
Commandments we can speculate that the demon Kings
full potential may be well over 500,000 we could
be tempted to think that because the demon king
gave up half of his powers to the commandments he
may have been more powerful than the supreme deity
if he had kept the powers to himself but we have
to remember that the supreme deity also gave the
power of the graces to the four Archangels and
the strength of the Archangels is comparable to
the power of the commandments so we can't really
assume that the demon king gave up more power to
his subordinates than the supreme deity did and
speaking of the supreme deity she is the mother
of the goddess Elisabeth and as I said before
she has the power to bestow Grace's upon the
Archangels she also has the ability to create
nearly unbreakable curses such as the one she
used on Elisabeth to control the elements and to
destroy entire cities she apparently has immunity
against all demonic curses and in general the
supreme deities abilities are believed to be
super effective against the demon clan which could
indicate that in a one-on-one battle the supreme
deity would actually defeat the demon king because
her powers seem to be super effective against his
type of power but that is just speculation
since we've never actually seen the supreme
deity in action we don't have any sort of power
level for the supreme deity and we haven't seen
much of her because she is believed to reside
in the celestial realm with that said if the
information that we have so far is true and the
supreme deity is really as strong as the demon
king then her power level could also be well over
half a million which would still be much higher
than any power level that has been revealed to us
up to this point and this means that the supreme
deity and the demon king are definitely the two
strongest characters in the seven deadly sins at
least for now and that is it the top 10 strongest
characters in the seven deadly sins ranked let me
know if you agree with this list and if not then
definitely let me know what you would change and
why as I said at the beginning of the video this
is not an exact science so your feedback and input
is welcome and appreciated if you enjoyed this
type of content and you want to see more you can
leave a like to let me know if you're new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification valve if you want to give us ideas
for future videos and stay in touch with all the
latest updates be sure to follow us on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar as always thank
you all so much for watching I really appreciate
it and until next time see us bass cowboys you